we are three days away from house of the
dragon and the old gods hbo have blessed
us with a new trailer i have been
feverishly rereading fire and blood and
compiling this uncompleted massive
family tree in preparation for the show
but today we're looking at this fire
will reign teaser spoilers ahead for
those of you who haven't read the book
let's sink our teeth into it an
absolutely glorious wide shot of king's
landing where its two most prominent
buildings the red keep and dragon pit
dominate the landscape there are a ton
of ships here but only one where we can
make out the sigil this is for house
valerian and house valerian is known for
their dominance of the sea you might
also have seen seven dragons in the air
here so if i were to hazard a guess this
is likely before the dance of dragons
has begun perhaps when damon targaryen
has come to king's landing to bend the
knee to his brother after his conquest
alongside corliss valerian against the
triarchy at the stepstones our next shot
is of adult alison's hightower sitting
in king viserys's chair at the small
council we've seen the king sit here in
the last trailer we'll have younger and
older versions of our characters appear
throughout the series as the events of
house of the dragons span centuries with
season 1 taking place roughly 200 years
before the events of game of thrones
notice the seven-pointed star necklace a
symbol of one's faith toward the new
gods a member of the kingsguard stands
watch behind her we can also see her
wearing a dark green outfit which is
contrasted with our next shot of renera
targaryen in black this is important
because the factions which split the
kingdom in two after the death of king
viserys are known as the greens and the
blacks this started long before the
dance of dragons at the queen's fifth
wedding anniversary where she wore a
beautiful green dress but was outdone by
rhaenyra in a dress of black from that
day forward those who supported queen
allison were known as the greens and
those who supported princess rhaenyra
the blacks i do love how the costume
designers have added these scales along
her dress mimicking her family's
connection with dragons here we have a
look at demon targaryen brother to king
viserys and future husband to rhaenyra
his niece this is likely dragonstone
judging by the background or somewhere
around driftmark considering the amount
of time he'll be spending alongside
corliss valerian this is followed by
members of the gold cloaks or the city
watch showing off their allegiance to
daemon who commanded them from about 104
to 105 ac now i cannot wait for this
this is the huge tournament that was put
on in 104 ac to celebrate king viserys's
ascension to the throne in the books
this takes place in maidenpool a town
north of king's landing however it looks
like they've moved it nearer to the city
as we can see the dragon pit on the top
left a lot of houses take part in this
we can see banners for house stark
baratheon and tully just to name a few
but a prominence of course is house
targaryen and slightly smaller house
valarian it's a bit hard to make out
here but you can see reinus rhaenyra
allison and corliss velaryon amongst
those in the royal box the two men here
are creston cole on the left and prince
daemon targaryen on the right damon's
getup here is pretty badass and i like
the addition of various squires in the
background ready to aid their knights as
the jousting continues this is a famous
battle where creston ends up defeating
damon knocking his famous sword dark
sister out of his hand with a morning
star he'll end up giving the
seven-year-old rhaenyra his victory
laurels but it looks as though they've
aged her up for the purposes of the show
here's a much better shot of rhaenyra
targaryen being told by her father that
they need to protect themselves from
whomever may challenge them what they're
talking about here are threats to the
secession for decades it's been
precedent that the throne passes on to
the eldest male heir bypassing any
females but viserys wants rhaenyra to
take the throne as we'll see throughout
the series there are many who do not
take kindly to this shake-up and will
claim they have a better right to the
throne than her so he's warning her to
be careful here we have some shots of
house velaryon's army there may be some
other westerosi forces in there led by
corliss engaging in battle this is
likely part of the war of the stepstones
in which he along with daemon targaryen
would go on to claim major victories
these victories due in part to damon's
control of his dragon karaxis who i
assume can be seen here just
obliterating the triarchy forces now we
get into the fun stuff the dragons i'm
going to be going off descriptions in
the book to best identify which dragon
is which but be warned that the designs
they use in the show could be different
here we have veigar the largest and
oldest dragon in westeros by the time of
house of the dragon she has survived
hundreds of battles which may explain
some of the tears in her wings tyrion
described her as having a huge gullet
able to fit an entire horse and we can
get a little bit of her scale here
compared to this actual mountain cliff
she is pretty damn huge the books
however never mention the color of her
scales horns or wings there is some sort
of building in the bottom left maybe
it's a castle or fortification i'm not a
hundred percent sure what it is two more
dragons here one of which has a rider on
it it's tough to see the dragon on the
left is sea smoke described in the books
as a pale silver gray dragon he was
ridden by lenore valerian who will go on
to marry rhaenyra the other dragon is
melees who is written by laenor's mother
raynus described as having scarlet
scales and crest horns and claws as
bright as copper this appears to be a
war council meeting run by renera at
dragonstone in front of her is a map of
westeros that same one we saw in the
latter seasons of game of thrones to our
left we can make out the backside of
daemon and to his right member of the
kingsguard now queensguard sir stephen
darklin who escaped king's landing after
aegon ii usurped the throne he also took
with him viserys's crown so that
rhaenyra could be coordinated queen so
we'll likely see that on screen as well
to his right is either grand maester
melos or grand maester gerardus finally
we have sir laurent marbrund a member of
the queensguard under stephan darklin as
war looms we get these massive velarian
ships i wonder if it's any way related
to that first shot we saw near the
beginning of the trailer targaryen sigil
drums beat i'm just loving the attention
to detail and costume designs here king
viserys moves away from the iron throne
holding blackfyre a valyrian steel sword
once wielded by aegon the conqueror to
his left is lord commander of the
kingsguard sir harold westerling this
looks to be sea smoke just absolutely
serving up some crispy delicious humans
likely triarchy members during the war
of the stepstones we'll see a
continuation of this shot here now check
out this almost indecipherable picture
of a man burning to death i think this
is sir harwin strong also known as break
bones the man believed to be the real
father of ranira's first three children
rumor had it that lenore rhaenyra's
first husband was gay thus rhaenyra
found companionship in sir harwood
however when king viserys heard about
this romance he had harwin move to
harrenhal where he died in a mysterious
fire depicted here we don't know who was
responsible for this fire but suspects
include damon corliss harwin's brother
and the king himself meles does a
drive-by against a targaryen ship if it
wanted to take this ship down it
certainly could more triarchy fighters
shooting arrows downward perhaps they're
on this cliff on the step zones which
will later get blasted by sea smoke
damon takes on this guy who some have
speculated is the same person seen here
from the teaser trailer this shot is of
lenor fighting in what appears to be
driftmark and it's possible damon was
here because for a time he was married
to laner's sister leina now this is
pretty sweet a shot of a baby dragon
likely sunfire it's hard to make out in
the darkness here but he's said to have
gleaming gold scales and pale pink
winged membranes he'll be ridden by king
aegon the second more dragons and what i
theorized is kragus drachar or crab
feeder the leader of the triarchy forces
hiding in a pirate's cave followed by
daemon in battle likely holding his
blade dark sister we'll later see damon
riding caraxes just completely
decimating the enemy forces at night we
get a brief image of the small council
likely this same night meeting where
viserys proclaims he won't make the
choice between his brother and daughter
when it comes to secession alongside him
is his hand otto hightower whose
daughter alicent the king will go on to
marry otto will become an enemy of both
daemon and rhaenyra our second last shot
is of king viserys and what is likely a
pregnant alicent hightower pregnant with
one of his children and finally this
appears to be princess rhaenyra riding
cyrax among the clouds i'm sure
separating the different dragons will
become easier as the show comes along
and we get a better sense of their
designs now i will be doing breakdowns
of the entire season i have not been
given screeners for the show but i'm
hoping to have those videos out within
24 hours of airing so make sure you're
subscribed with the bell notification on
to know exactly when they're out thanks
for watching everyone be sure to like
and subscribe and leave your thoughts
and theories for the show in the
comments below